Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar and you're watching Mind Your Decisions
Start out with a square with a side length of one
Draw another square, and then draw another square that connects to both of these squares
Finally draw a fourth square that is attached to this third square
We're going to construct a triangle
Well first draw the diagonal of the first square and then we'll connect it to this corner of the fourth square
The question is what is the area of this triangle?
I Adapted this from a puzzle by Catriona Shearer who's on Twitter @Cshearer41
And I read it on the blog, Math With Bad Drawings
Can you figure it out? Give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for a solution
So, how can we solve this problem? Let's get a different perspective by rotating the entire diagram
Now, let's label some of the lengths
The small square has a side length of one
And the larger square will have a side length that's equal to two of these small squares.
So, it'll be equal to two
The base of the triangle is along this line
Now, the height will be along the perpendicular to this line
And let's just create a little rectangular grid and by doing so,
We can see that the height of this triangle is along and exactly equal to the diagonal of the square with a side length of 2
So now let's calculate the base and height of this triangle
The base of this triangle is the diagonal of a square with a side length of one
So it's base will be equal to the square root of two
The height of the triangle is the diagonal of a square with a side length of two
so this length will be two times the square root of two
And now we figured out the important dimensions we need
The area of a triangle is equal to its base times its height all over two
We've calculated the base and we've calculated the height and this simplifies to be equal to two and that's our answer
Amazingly we can solve this problem without knowing the height of the fourth square. Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video these math videos, which can be watched for free on YouTube
Inspire and build confidence for people around the world and they already have over a hundred million views
Let's share the beauty of mathematics with your help, we can make the world a better place
Please subscribe for free to get the newest videos. Watch and share all of Mind Your Decisions' videos.
Email me a puzzle or math topic presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com. If you so choose you can check out my books
which are listed in the video description. And you can support me on Patreon for exclusive rewards.
Thanks for watching, and thanks for your support.